The people that are on
your team, the people that
are in your group,
your family, whoever.
You're coaching, you
might not even know it,
but you're coaching.
For you, as a team
leader, you're
only going to be
able to do it if you
can build great relationships.
We've won 11 national
championships in the last 25
years.
I won two gold medals
at the Olympics
coaching the US national team.
Teams are teams, no
matter what situation.
It's a group of people
trying to come together
to do something that they
can't do individually.
Some of the things that
you're going to learn
are: how to get the best
people on your team--
that's number one, that's
key-- how to work with them so
that you can raise
their level from where
they are, to where
they hope to be,
to where you need them to be.
It's the same in sports, and
it's the same in business,
and it's the same in life.
How do we build those
championship teams?
How do we train those
incredible players?
I go by the old-fashioned
Catholic Italian way.
You just make them feel guilty.
So you ask them, flat-out,
"is this the best you got?"
and invariably, they'll
say, "no, I got more."
All right.
Let's go.
Let's see it.
One of the biggest attributes
that resilient leaders
have, is the ability to listen,
listen more than you talk,
because when I got
to this country,
I didn't speak English.
So you're kind of
forced to grow up fast.
Pay attention and
learn by watching,
and learn by listening.
I truly believe
there's always pressure
when you're trying to
accomplish something that's
meaningful and rewarding;
and because of the pressure
and because you perform and
you handle it a certain way,
you've just grown as a person.
You've just become something
more than what you were before.
Winning teams, understand that
the pursuit of winning never
ends.
Winning a game, is
really teaching you
how to win at life.
Any group can benefit
from the strategies
we're going to talk about;
and you, as a leader,
can help them reach
their potential.
I'm Geno Auriemma, and
this is MasterClass.